people are saying the wildest [ __ ] just  for the sake of saying it and they're  doing great it goes back to how  impressionable people's brains are Mr  Rogers had it right kids are  impressionable you have to get to them  early teach them like ethics and values  and all this stuff very early that  carries forward throughout their lives  like Andrew Tate is going to take the  spot oh [ __ ] he's not even Mr Rogers  imagine [ __ ] Hezbollah was YouTube  videos teaching children how to behave  well I think I think that's okay  I'm a big fan so hospital is okay for  the kids it's either Hammer Alex Jones I  like Hospital though those are our top  three I like him when he was playing  with the pigeon yeah I'm talking about  it you're talking about the little kid  yeah and I'm talking about Hezbollah  Hezbollah yeah  [Laughter]  what the [ __ ]